When an entrepreneur goes to me and
investor for the first time,
I think that the most important thing
to be able to do, is articulate what
your business is and what your
vision is, quickly and so simply.
People talk about pitch decks as being
ten slides is like an ideal thing.
Now imagine if you're just going and
meeting somebody for coffee or
you're standing in a conference
in years just talking to them.
It's got to be even more
condensed than that.
And you have to be able
to demonstrate passion,
knowledge of what the business is and
a real plan to succeed.
And you have to be able
to do that quickly.
And it takes a lot of
practice to get there.